Here's one way to define add page to index.
We're defining a procedure that takes in 3 inputs--
the index, the URL and the content at that location--
We use the split method to divide the content into its component words.
We store that into the words variable.
Then what we want to do is go through all of the words, adding each word into the index.
We can do that using a 4-loop.
We're going through all of the words, we'll use word as our variable.
For each word, we call add to index, pass in to index the word and the URL.
Note that if a word occurs more than once on the same page,
we're going to keep adding it to the index each time.
There might be more than one occurrence of the same URL
in the list of URLs associated with a word.
Depending on what we want our search engine to do,
and how we are going to decide on how to respond to queries,
this might be a good thing or a bad thing. We'll talk more about that in a later class.
Let's try this in the Python interpreter.
Let's recap the code we already wrote--
we have the add to index procedure--
that takes in the index, the keyword and the URL.
It goes through the entries in the index,
and it appends the URLs to the entries that matches the keyword.
If it's not found, it adds a new entry to the index,
that's the list of the keyword, and the single URL.
We defined the lookup procedure that takes the index and the keyword,
finds the entry in the index that corresponds to that keyword,
and returns the URLs associated with that keyword.
So, now we're going to define the add page to index procedure.
So, here it is, we're splitting the content into it's component words,
we're looping through the words, and we're adding each word to the index--
note that we don't need to return anything--
the point of this procedure is to modify the index.
Let's try add page to index with a few simple examples.
Here we have the test we tried before--
we see that we get the expected result--
if we're adding the first quote to the index, we see that there is the 4 words in the quote
each has the list of pages associated with it--the list of URLs contains fake.test.
Then we added the 2nd page, the 2nd print we see,
now for most of the words we have both fake.test and not.test except for not,
which only has not.test.
So, to be really convinced that this works, let's try a few more interesting examples.
Now we're going to add page to index that might be on the dilbert.com page--
this quote from Scott Adams about time management--
"Another strategy is to ignore the fact that you're slowly killing yourself
by not sleeping and exercising enough
that frees up several hours a day, the only down side is that you get fat and die."
Hopefully that is not happening to anyone in this class.
I know that it's a lot of work,
but you need to manage your time so that you're still getting enough sleep and exercise.
The second quote we'll add to the page index and we'll give the URL randy.pousch for that.
And it's a quote that says "Good judgement comes from experience,
experience comes from bad judgement.
If things aren't going well,
it probably means you are learning a lot and things will go better later."
So, hopefully things are going well in this class,
but if they're not, that means you're learning a lot and hopefully things will go better later.
Let's see what the index looks like after adding these 2 pages.
You see that it is pretty big, there are a lot of words in those 2 quotes.
We can see that some of them only appear at dilbert.com
and from the quote from Scott Adams on time management--
others appear on both pages--
We'll see more if we try a query. Let's try a query.
We'll look up in our index to see where the word you appears.
And when we run that, we see it appears in both documents.
It was there in the dilbert quote twice, it was listed 2 times at the URL dilbert.com
and once and the Randy Pousch URL.
Just to confirm, the 2 occurrences in this quote, there is one here--and there's one here.
And there's one in the second quote right here.
If we look up another word, we see good did not occur in any of the quotes,
but bad appeared in the 2nd one.
So, it looks like all the code that we have seems to be working.
We can look up words that are indexed and get the list of URLs where they were found.
We can add pages to our index.
And we can record all of the words in that page at the location they occur.
We're really close to having a search engine.
The one thing that we have left to do
is to connect the code we already wrote for crawling the web to
the code that we have for indexing documents and looking up the keywords.
It's been awhile since we looked at the code for crawling the web.
Let's look at that again and see if we can think how to connect the two.